how you doing people I'm Dave Ruben this
is the Ruben report and we are doing the
biggest gayest show we've done we do a
lot of gay stuff here it's been a big
gay year usually good news I have
brought two of YouTube's gayest gay
Superstars Hank Chen Davey wavy I'll
take it are you guys the gayest ones you
guys were I look through the list of gay
YouTube people and both of you were on
the top of the list there and here we
are I'll take it you're ready to be gay
and do some more we're on YouTube right
now so this is this should be very
comfortable oh hi this is so exciting
there you go all right let's talk some
gay stuff we actually got some great gay
news this morning uh Derek Gordon who is
a division one basketball player at
UMass came out he is the first division
one basketball player to come out this
of course comes on the heels of Jason
Collins in the NBA Michael Sam uh NCAA
football player who will make it to the
NFL in a couple of months uh you guys
are big jocks right totally two two big
jocks here to talk sports I've been
working out yeah can we agree that uh
whether you're an athlete or a sports
fan or not can we agree that having
another out athlete is all good this
this is just good news right I love it I
I I think any kind of visibility no
matter who it is is fantastic I I think
the power of coming out is through the
individual and not through like policies
and government thingies and laws and
stuff like that it has to be that
personal connection so I'm sure he's got
that ripple effect of his immediate
circle and that's going you know the
people now have to process that and
decide whether to accept him for who he
is or cut it off yeah hopefully it's the
for all good all good well I mean and
it's it's it's breaking stereotypes it's
like this is a guy who's not a
hairdresser which is what we see with
gay people on TV he's he's something
different um I mean the question that we
had was is he any good yeah so he's
pretty decent that's what
I basketball is the dribbling one orange
ball right with the orange ball yeah
through the did they kick the hoop and
the net I like that one that one's fun
yeah yeah we'll deal with all that later
so okay so if it's all good when do we
get to stop celebrating this stuff
because I think at some point we do have
to get past like everybody that comes
out we have to like go crazy about it it
literally is the number one trending
thing on Twitter as of our taping this
like when are we are we close to that
point where we can just be like oh you
came out great we're just not right
we're not I hope never though well I I
this makes me think I shouldn't have
come out I should have like held it a
secret for a few years and then like had
this big thing cuz you get so much
publicity from it like none of us would
ever be talking about this guy he
wouldn't be trending on Twitter but now
he is and and it's great that he came
out but this is like millions and
millions of dollars of publicity yeah I
think that's an interesting point so for
three public people that are out is is
there a little bit of resentment or
something obviously we're not NCAA
athletes but is there a little bit of
like oh I could have held it in until
something big happened and then it would
have been even bigger or something like
that I could not have held it in anyone
who went to middle school knows that I
could not have held it in but also I I
don't think I would be here sitting at
this desk with you had I not come out
YouTube was my public outing and to
answer an earlier question I feel like
we should never stop celebrating I mean
are we really going to at a certain
point cancel the Gay Pride perade
because it's no longer relevant I hope
every year that every year that it's
pride month people do talk about that so
no because every time a black person
wins an Oscar I feel like that's also
noteworthy and that and the Civil Rights
you know for for other groups has has
continued in spite of its longer history
than the gay rights movement it's great
do you guys think that the the sports
thing is more about the fear from the
media or actually what goes on in the
locker room because that's what everyone
thinks that somehow if there's a gay
person in the locker room even though
there obviously have been gay people in
the locker room forever long time for a
long time that somehow that's the
players are going to freak out but I I
to me it's more about the media how the
media is going to react than the actual
players I really think they're going to
be okay with people probably just don't
care like it's 2014 and the players are
probably like you like dick that's great
like
right let's go play the game but it's
kind of I think the it's like the it's
become the talking point this year it's
like that next barrier the next thing to
break through yeah when do you think
last question on this when do you think
we will have an openly straight WNBA
player o I say 10 years did you get the
joke there you got the joke yes I did I
uh I I hopefully soon a lot of lesbians
in that League we we support we support
you what I want to say I think that's a
perfect finish we openly support
straight women in the
WNBA